the decades-long opioid epidemic in the
U.S was once dominated by drugs like
heroin and oxy but with the rise of
fentanyl perhaps the most dangerous
phase is now upon us
in the first two years the pandemic more
people were killed by fentanyl than ever
before the coveted pandemic helped pave
the way for fentanyl's Ascent as
isolation and boredom drove people to
substance abuse there have been more
than 165 000 opioid deaths since the
start of covet most of those deaths
involved synthetic opioids like fentanyl
fentanyl was first developed as a
stronger kind of painkiller it's cheap
and the street version is abundant it's
more than 100 times more powerful than
morphine and 50 times more powerful than
heroin just two milligrams of fentanyl
around the size of a few grains of salt
can cause a fatal overdose fentanyl is
now infiltrating other kinds of drugs
including heroin and cocaine as well as
counterfeit prescription pills that
means people with an opioid addiction
are at risk and so are users of cocaine
black market Adderall meth marijuana and
other substances powerful drug is often
used to strengthen or stretch sock piles
of other illicit drugs the precursor
chemicals used to make fentanyl are also
globally available according to the Drug
Enforcement Administration a lot of
illicit fentanyl is made abroad and
smuggled into the U.S through Mexico in
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis has
described this situation as a problem of
law enforcement and border control he
has responded by increasing Florida's
penalties for opioid cell and
distribution and he announced a program
that connects patients with treatments
like Naltrexone and methadone to help
treat addiction similar techniques like
syringe exchanges are part of what's
known as harm reduction a movement to
decrease the risks associated with drug
use but some harm reduction techniques
have been rejected by conservative
elected officials who say they instead
enable drug use another tactic is the
distribution of fentanyl strips which
can be used to test for the powerful
substance in other drugs but the strips
are considered illegal drug
paraphernalia in about half of U.S
states including Florida according to
Kaiser health news Florida's
republican-controlled legislature
recently shut down an effort to change
that in Florida which skews older and is
more than a quarter hispanic most of
those who are dying of opioid overdoses
are white and more than half are younger
than 45 but with fentanyl use on the
upswing the death rate among black
people has overtaken white people and
overdoses among Native Americans are
also increasing disproportionately